it is all about these documents and make
no mistake the overnight developments
are huge legally and politically federal
charges against a former president it is
unprecedented
it was he who announced the news getting
ahead of the prosecutors owning the
moment and the narrative
they go after a popular president a
president that got more votes than any
sitting president in the history of our
country by far
and did much better the second time in
the election than
the first
and they go after him on a Box's hoax
just like the Russia Russia Russia Hooks
and all of the others this has been
going on for seven years that they can't
stop because it's election interference
at the highest level there's never been
anything like what's happened I'm an
innocent man I'm an innocent person
this is the scene of the alleged crime
or crimes Mar-A-Lago his Florida Resort
in August last year the FBI raided this
home of a former president at the heart
of the case of 15 boxes containing 184
documents marked as confidential secret
and top secret witness testimony and
CCTV were collected
then this man Jack Smith a judge
respected on both sides was appointed by
the Attorney General as special counsel
to take on the case a grand jury of
ordinary Americans examined it the
conclusion there is a case for Mr Trump
to answer the former president is here
at his New Jersey golf course in
Bedminster and those close to him who
are with Him have said he is in good
spirits and that he will fight this
he said to be huddled with advisors
working out his next move
Glenn kirschner is a former Federal
prosecutor he will be fingerprinted he
will have his arrest photo taken and
then he will be transported to court
where he'll make his first court
appearance the indictment will be read
he will enter a plea presumably of not
guilty they'll turn their attention to
what conditions of release the judge
might set for Donald Trump then they
will pick a next court date top
Republicans are reacting already this is
hugely politically charged
Speaker of the House Kevin McCarthy
wrote Today is indeed a dark day for the
United States of America it is
unconscionable for a president to indict
the leading candidate opposing him Joe
Biden kept classified documents for
decades I and every other American who
believes in the rule of law stand with
President Trump against this grave
Injustice House Republicans will hold
this Brazen weaponization of power
accountable it is the voters who will
drive the direction of all this remember
he is Far and Away the favorite to be
the Republican candidate for the
presidency and a trial may not conclude
before the election
in April he was indicted in a New York
District Court over hush money payments
to a porn star they were not federal
charges
then a civil jury found him liable for
the sexual abuse of this woman
journalist e Gene Carroll his polling
went up
the question is what happens now is
there a limit in this country to what a
presidential candidate can be embroiled
in brace for Jeopardy and turbulence
ahead